we switched gears now to the major news
out of Washington today former Trump
campaign manager Paul Manafort had a
deal with Robert Motor Special Counsel
investigation joining us now with
reaction the president's on the
president's perspective on the matter is
his attorney Rudy Giuliani former New
York City Mayor mr. mayor good to see
you on the Madison issue I have been
told by numerous of multiple sources
close to mana Ford and others that in
fact whatever cooperation is going to
take place is not what is being reported
it would have nothing to do with the
campaign Donald Trump Russia collusion
of any kind but more to do with lobbying
and other groups well Sean that's
absolutely true I mean the reality is
there was a quote put out by a source
close to Manta Ford that the plea
agreement has and the cooperation
agreement has nothing to do with the
Trump campaign quote there is no
evidence of collusion now I know that
because I've been privy to a lot of
facts I can't repeat but the reality is
no evidence of collusion all you have to
do is look at the plea the plea is two
crimes that have to do with mana Ford's
past no involvement with President Trump
no involvement with the campaign no
involvement with Russia and by the way
there's also no evidence of obstruction
there have been four guilty pleas now
and they're completely irrelevant
well you agree with me mr. mayor you
know look I know you not only is New
York City's mayor but you're one of the
toughest prosecutors in the Southern
District of New York you were right
there putting your life on the line
taken down some of the the toughest
crime families in the country at the
time but do you agree with me that the
integrity of institutions like the FBI
the CIA and the DOJ and the Intel
community now hanging in a balance
because what have we discovered here
that the FB I first got Hillary off the
hook they fixed what we'll obvious
crimes she committed that they were
involved in spreading propaganda
misinformation through her bought and
paid for dossier that they also used it
to get a FISA warrant they lied to FISA
Court judges and committed a fraud on
the court but the level of leaking and
lying and conspiracy to hurt
then candidate Trump and then President
Trump it's all here we have the
information there is evidence there's no
question about it here here's the
collusion strangely Shawn the collusion
is that whole group of people struck
page or ORS wife Comey Brennan clapper
they decided to first keep him out of
the White House so we get the dossier
paid for by Hillary Clinton a million
dollars by the way to pay for the phony
thing never reveal properly to the court
by the way completely fraudulent five
their wires leaked illegally now
admitted total crime as Gregg Jarrett
points out both in his book and now with
you and then finally when they failed in
that mission they just transitioned
right into trying to drive him out of
the White House yeah so this is not this
is not an investigation based on any
facts there's never been a single fact
produced that President Trump in any way
colluded with anybody much less
conspired with them it was the bear the
man is totally innocent we do know the
FBI we do know the DOJ we do know that
the then DNI we know the CIA all had a
media leak strategy all related to
destroying Donald Trump before the
election after the election and not only
that with all due respect I guess you
got to do business with the guy I don't
but when we look at the messages from
steel to Bruce or his wife of course
worked for fusion GPS but Christopher
steel have put all the Russian lies
together paid for by Hillary he's
talking about praying he doesn't get
exposed he's also talking about
firewalls holding struck in Page talk
about an insurance policy but then steel
tells or asking or hey did you get the
information that we now know are
fabricated lies from Russia did you get
them into the special counsel's office
that goes into Robert Muller's office
he's now tainted by this heresy you that
if there's the same relentless pursuit
of these people as they've done to
President Trump you're gonna find very
quickly already admitted
evidence of serious crimes and a major
conspiracy to first stop him from being
president and then to create
circumstances whether it be an
impeachment and this is my head hangs in
shame
for the department that I gave 16 years
of my life to the Department of Justice
I have the third ranking official in the
Department of Justice when I could
proudly say it was a Department of
Justice and the only thing that could be
done now is as relentless and
investigation of all these people as
they did the president Trump all right
mr. mayor thank you for being ladies we
appreciate it